nous allons dans le public karen qui est
un peu sur cette quête un peu sur cette
ligne tu voulais bien vous vous relevez
karen vous vous pensez aussi que les
mesures prises par le gouvernement sont
excessives normalement votre micro est
ouvert
bonsoir a tous déjà merci beaucoup de
m'accueillir sur ce plateau
alors moi je vais être très très clair
alors moi mon objectif ici c'est
d'apporter un beau témoignage plein
d'amour plein d'espoir parce que tout ce
qu'on nous prêchent en ce moment c'est
le chaos chaotique et ça fait très peur
et moi si je suis là aujourd'hui en fait
c'est parce que j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
dans ma vie qui a touché mon coeur et
cette personne c'est jésus christ ouais
ouais cassure alors je sais qu'il ya des
chrétiens ici des musulmans voilà des
voilà vraiment des personnes qui ont la
foi moi j'ai la foi j'ai l'espérance et
je sais que le christ revient c'est
vraiment un message d'amour déjà je vous
bénis tous je vous aime tous sachez que
dieu vous aime jésus vous aime et il a
donné sa vie à la croix pour vous tous
pour vous sauver de vos péchés parce
qu'un jour ce monde là il va passer et
nous en fait dès vendredi matin n'a pas
dimanche matin sur france 2 non et donc
n'achète pas une presse en fait parce
que dieu n'est pas une religion dieu
c'est une relation avant tout et moi
j'ai vraiment cette relation personnelle
avec mon père non mais je l'entends bien
mais là on parle voilà du convient de
exactement et on pense je faisais le
lien risque 10 et yann qui maintenant en
étant peu embarrassé évidemment ce raout
en fait depuis tout à l'heure vous vous
trouvez non vous trouvez aussi que les
mesures prises contre le hula covit sont
excessives
expliquez-nous ça pas tant que ça fait
passer votre message sur jésus-christ
alors moi je trouve excessif parce que
justement ben on en sort des schémas de
pensée unique et dont
- bon voilà je respecte les règles tout
ça si ça peut en en
comment dirais-je en rassurer certains
pourquoi pas mais moi j'y crois pas du
tout c'est pas parce qu'on va me faire
porter un masque que je vais forcément
bas penser pareil que des gens qui ont
peur par exemple voilà
mais dans quel but vous pensez qu'on
oblige les gens à porter des masques et
qui selon vous ne servirait à rien ou
pas droit tout est écrit justement dans
la bible et dans les écrits coranique
c'est qu'en fait ce qu'on vient en ce
moment c'est la fin des temps donc il ya
des révélations du coup laurent
confinement à tous eric il ya quelque
chose de hyannis port où le sentiment
chez des gens d'eschatologie de
messianisme et on vit effectivement ce
virus exactement ce que j'étais en train
de dire on vit ce virus comme un signe
de la fin des temps alors que c'est un
virus c'est un virus que mahut en 1968
qui a eu une grippe
il ya eu la grippe espagnole il ya des
virus saisonniers qui tue ou qui ne tue
pas celui là il a un peu spécial mais
effectivement il ya un sentiment de fin
du monde
exactement de millénarisme qui se passe
en ce moment qu'il me semblait
évidemment le problème n'avait vous êtes
plutôt un symptôme de ce que je décris
oui c'est à dire vous corroborer ce que
je disais c'est que il y a des gens
comme vous qui pensent que l'arrivée de
ce virus signifie quelque chose
oui alors moi je pense que ça signifie
qui est juste eu un virus un virus
désagréable un virus qui a tué mais un
virus karen je me permets de dire vous
dit exactement mais vous êtes en parfait
désaccord
c'est très bizarre les réponses que vous
faites non ce que je disais par là c'est
que fin voilà mon message avant tout
c'était vraiment partager l'amour en
fait sur le plateau parce qu on auprès
des russes et moi c'est vrai que j'en ai
marre je pense que beaucoup d'entre nous
en ont marre est ce qu'on entend pas
assez en fait c'est par exemple pas dieu
et jésus christ parce que on nous dit en
fait que l'homme n'a pas besoin de dieu
pour pour subsister mais en fait on en a
vraiment besoin dans une société comme
ça et je pense que parmi vous parmi tous
les gens qui regardent la télé voilà moi
je prends le risque de me faire humilier
mais c'est pas grave parce que moi je
trouve que cette vérité dans ce monde
ces voix là c'est vraiment jésus qui est
mort à la croix répandez l'amour mais
pas le virus ne pardonnez moi moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour votre foi je
pense que la foi est une brûlure et on
n'a pas à la contester c'est très intime
en revanche on vous dit que vous
répartissez de l'amour
permettez moi de vous contredire car ce
virus si vous si votre thèse c'est qu'on
va lutter contre grâce à des prières
vous mettez les gens et vos congénères
en danger n'est pas j'essaie d'amour
madame c'est un geste de mise en danger
elle n'a pas dit ça jelavic est resté le
même et elle te parle partout à manger
dit que moi je respecte et les gestes
barrière mais sachez madame que le
meilleur médecin du monde c'est jésus
christ parce que en fait on a compris
pour les malades et ya des miracles
richement alors jusqu'au bout dit saouad
à réunir des gens qui sont là et qui du
coup vont pas chez le médecin il ya vous
mettez des gens en danger nelson matin
j'ai voyagé la preuve c'est la preuve de
la raison pour laquelle il faut mieux
pourquoi avoir des discussions que
chacun garde des questions religieuses
dans l'intimité parce que comme le dogme
par définition ne peut jamais discuté
entre je pourrai jamais vous convaincre
vous pourrez pas me convaincre le dogme
par définition ne se discute pas c'est
la raison pour laquelle ce pays a forgé
une notion lumineuse qui s'appelle la
laïcité
je voudrais qu'on avance